allez des théâtres on va passer à la
musique à musique avec de l'énergie en
plateau avec nous le groupe wasabi alors
vous êtes 6 bonsoir messieurs 66 et là
il ya que 4 parce qu'on peut pas
accueillir les six membres du groupe
donc y est vous êtes venu à 4 on peut
dire que c'est un groupe rock électro
pour définir un groupe fusion rock
électro on essaie de mélanger pas mal de
genre et que chaque musique un univers
un peu différent donc on s'inspire des
groupes comme shaka ponk chili kings
park papa roach aussi d'orchies carrier
ça c'est damien qui parle
et ouais c'est moi damien plaque terme à
cette dernière justement vous êtes alors
moi j'ai eu ma première question c'est
wasabi c'est un groupe i quand
exactement
ouais on essaye ce faire la musique qui
donne envie de bouger qui donne en fait
voilà envie de pogoter donc toujours la
musique typique donc voilà pourquoi au
wasabi et brouillard savage et une belle
dune ah bah oui mais bon quoi mais tous
mes amis pour ce que peut-être qu'ils ne
savent pas c'est quand même plutôt un
produit alimentaire de la cuisine
japonaise qui piquent horriblement à la
langue et c'est aussi pour vous en tout
cas c'est des initiales qui en français
veulent dire on est sauvage est très
affecté voilà soulagés très affecté
d'accord sur le damier effectivement
vous êtes vous êtes
précurseur du groupe s'étoffe avec
l'échalote parce qu'il est pas dans les
loges mais qui est pas en plateau avec
nous parlez nous un peu de l'histoire
puis présenter vos camarades
alors moi c'est damien chanteur bassiste
greg guitariste stéphane guitariste et
claviériste comment le groupe a évolué
depuis 2009 ben en fait on a on était
deux à la base on a commencé à composer
à deux avec charlotte donc grâce à un
ami on a enregistré chez lui on a vu ce
que ça pouvait donner à trouver grail et
après on a on a eu un peu de mal à
trouver les autres membres après c'était
fans est arrivé c'était en 2010 c'est ca
2010 mais début 2010 sur cette voie là
et après on a un peu ramé avant de
trouver donc vincent qui est le batteur
et on s'est dit pourquoi pas ajouter une
petite touche d'électro donc et c'est là
qu'on a trouvé dany le cas maintenant
donc vous êtes si ça y est vous êtes au
complet là on est au complet
vous sortez votre deuxième pet exact
album 7 sur cet ep
même si me bats chaque musique un
univers un peu différent d'aller musique
où je chante plus ou charlotte chante
plus
plus il y en a qui sont plus punk plus
métal pour que chacun s'y retrouve en
fait en écoutant le p j'ai pas dit parce
que j'ai oublié de dire vous êtes membre
de l'association turbulences qui est une
association de benz est aussi soutenu
par le cri qui est le centre de
ressources illinois pour pour la musique
c'est important de faire partie d'une
association
ça ouvre des portes enfin me ce truc de
pic depuis qu'on est con et d'un statut
social sion en fait on a
je trouve qu'on est un peu plus
accompagner un peu plus soutenu et c'est
vrai que ça nous offre ça nous a offert
à aussi des nous a ouvert des portes en
fait notamment avec le cri qui nous a
permis justement de quand vous dites ses
fans que vous n'êtes plus soutenu c'est
à dire que musicalement vous pouvez
suivre des formations c'est dans ceux là
soutenu où c'est
c'est vrai que vous retrouvez avec
d'autres groupes et quand on n'est pas
tout seul c'est plus facile quoi bah
disons que voilà dans une association
enfin il ya il ya quand même un
bénéficie aussi de soutiens que ce soit
logistique notamment pour l'année
prochaine préparation de concerts qu'on
va faire on aura un soutien mais aussi
on a un peu un accompagnement
un accompagnement qui très intéressant
que le cri aussi propose aussi des
formations qui peuvent qui sont vraiment
intéressantes aussi à 1 pour nous comme
pour plus tard quand on va parler d'en
parler dans de vos sources d'inspiration
vous allez m'expliquer comment vous
travaillez parce que gekko stéphane
quand on est élu au téléphone tout à
l'heure a expliqué vous travaillez pour
vous aimerez expliquer ça parce qu'en
gros c'est un vaste mélange de tout
essayer tout le monde on n'en dit pas
plus on va écouter quand même votre
musique parce que elle elle l'énergie ça
c'est peu de le dire on va regarder cet
extrait donc de wasabi
une fois pas deux
comment tu sais
sur le site
merci
fait fort
merzouk en concert ça va donner un
savoir mais alors là ça le pogo voilà ça
on est tout en sueur mais on est content
c'est clair inspiration donc moi c'est
surtout papa roach et les kings park
donc je me suis inspiré pour la voix et
le jeu de basse au début j'étais un peu
inspiré red hot chili peppers pour
commencer mais après tout ce qui est
musique punk des envies de bouger vous
composé en anglais c'est obligatoire de
composer en anglais composé en anglais
we
déjà parce que au niveau de la musique
qu'on fait c'est ça passe beaucoup mieux
parce qu'en français on a déjà essayé
sur une composition qu'on a répété
c'était pas ça n'est pas vraiment un
très très bon rendu donc on s'est dit
bon on va continuer comme ça qu'on pose
en anglais et puis
ça passe mieux enfin nous on veut je te
manque sa passe dans peut-être dans
d'autres pays on sait jamais peut-être
se faire connaître ailleurs c'est plus
simple quand voilà voilà
alors comment ses fans comment sont
composés les textes alors il parle de
quoi vos textes
c'est plus c'est plus damien a laissé
plus damien et charlotte qui se classait
pour des jeux texte on fait déjà propose
la musique
et selon ce qu'elle nous inspire d'abord
la musique il abhorre la musique sinon
cela nous inspire on écrit les textes
alors des fois c'est moi qui écris des
fois c'est charlotte et par rapport à un
thème commun ça dépend des musiques en
fête
chaque musique un thème différent non il
n'y a pas de pas de message c'est plutôt
comme chaque musique un petit univers
une petite histoire à raconter c'est
vraiment pour que chacun y retrouve ce
qu'ils cherchent voilà deuxième ep the
lady qui vient de sortir on peut le se
procurer comment on peut le récupérer
directement en fait sur sur notre
facebook en fait donc
facebook.com c'est donc voilà on peut le
télécharger les garder on est aussi sur
deezer ceux-ci teaser est une et spotify
mais on peut les acheter soit séparément
ou télécharger directement le notre pays
d'accord un dernier mot sur les concerts
à venir celui du 12 avril ses plus
proches donc 12 avril à zenica pas
parler alors là on sait le thalys tous
sur dany on est sur un regroupement
pas beaucoup entendue alors c'est vrai
le concert du 12 avril à trappes
le concert du 2 avril on va le faire en
acoustique
c'est une première pour vos habits
acoustique c'est parce que c'est la
salle qui du coup s'y prête comme ça
c'est un peu ce que c'est sympa ça qu'il
voulait c'est un peu ça par rapport à la
seule mais aussi pour essayer de se
diversifier un peu dans notre musique
c'est vrai que le côté électro c'est
très bien mais si on veut toucher un peu
plus de public
c'est vrai que l'acoustique ça peut
essayer de ça peut nous permettre
d'avoir plus de public effectivement
wasabi en acoustique c'est avec
étonnement c'est un univers complètement
différent là vous proposez c'est à dire
que
suivre les répétitions qu'on a eu
dernièrement on s'est rendu compte que
l'énergie qui a électriquement se
retrouvent aussi caustique menton autant
essayer de faire ça enlève donc à
découvrir le 12 avril au centre culturel
de trappes prochain un autre concert le
21 avril au club avec un petit club avec
un casque pour sa part ça sera un
concert plus normal plus classique pour
vous well électrique
cette fois d'accord autre date que j'ai
noté aussi de 21,6 et le lendemain ça
sera aussi normal peut-être à
rambouillet aussi donc d'accord donc
vous tourner quand même pas mal dans les
résumés dans les yvelines où on essaie
d'être fait un peu plus d d'analysé been
d'accord merci à vous quatre d'être
venir plateau qui on salue les deux
autres qui sont dans les loges charlotte
est insensible
alors les saluts qui nous fait un petit
coucou être alors la vitre voilà à saint
lô en tout cas donc vous avez découvert
l'univers musical du groupe
wasabi